le 27 avril journée de fête nationale
aux pays-bas ce mardi les néerlandais
célébrer le 54ème anniversaire de leroy
willem alexander cet événement
traditionnellement placée sous le signe
de la liesse populaire a également été
l'occasion d'une importante
manifestation contre le gouvernement
les restrictions contre le coc vie 19 et
la politique vaccinale les gens se
battent pour la liberté comme nous le
faisons tous à travers le monde
[Musique]
il y a un groupe de gens qui sont
censurés par ce qu'ils veulent
s'exprimer pour leur propre libre
arbitre on leur a refusé de dire par
exemple qu'ils veulent prendre leurs
propres décisions sur leur vie sur leur
corps sur la vaccination ou non de leurs
enfants
[Musique]
le gouvernement n'est pas bon hier ils
ont dit que nous allions donner des
millions allende
mais nous avons besoin de cet argent aux
pays bas il faut d'abord commencer par
son propre peuple
l'alimentation les banques de nourriture
je ne sais pas comment le dire en
anglais mais nous avons besoin de
maisons
nous avons des gens sans maison ils
dorment sous les ponts il faut d'abord
commencer avec son propre peuple
et si tout va bien alors on peut penser
au reste en janvier dernier une partie
de la population avait déjà exprimé son
mécontentement
de violents affrontements avaient alors
éclaté entre des manifestants et les
forces de l'ordre
le rassemblement de ce mardi intervient
alors que le gouvernement allège les
restrictions en place contre le coc vite
19 ce mercredi depuis 4h30 7 nuits le
couvre-feu a été levé dans le pays
les bars et restaurants pourront quant à
eux servir en terrasse entre midi et 18h